for me I left school of sixteen in
England I came from a family love my mom
and dad daily but you know they work
together and you know it was a tough
environment it was it was a very very
tough environment as I said left school
at 16 went straight into dead-end jobs
working minimum wage in factories one
thing at what shitty job the shittiest
jobs I could ever [ __ ] imagine really
you name it I've done em all yeah oh god
what are you doing over there anything
and everything you know driving a
forklift working in a slaughterhouse
[ __ ] [ __ ] furniture you know not
door-to-door sales yeah double glazing
nuts no double glazing windows doughnuts
yeah you have much more success selling
double glazed doughnut to me now yeah
yeah exactly you're right yeah no double
glazed windows well it solves a lot of
them it's not like a scam is it do you
know he's like modern windows you know
double glazed windows so what were you
guys using before that
just [ __ ] single single glazed no
everyone else double glazed windows you
probably have double glazed windows and
anyway so he's trying to get people to
do that and I was never selling much
yeah I didn't think you were so like
Oprah so back then I was way bigger way
bigger yeah and I had a shaved head and
you know I yeah I was at and my boss was
like you're not selling very much
Michael I'm like yeah it's like you
think you mean a bit intimidating at the
door because you're a pretty loud big
person I'm like no I don't think it was
gonna buy a glass window
yeah sign up so anyway yeah I did you
know all these shitty jobs and then you
know I'd met my wife when we had two
kids and I was working as a quality
control inspector at a furniture store
Furniture Factory and my boss there a
great guy nice guy very intelligent and
we would chat away and he used to say to
me say Michael you're a smart kid is
this what you want to do for the rest of
your life well I was like [ __ ] no he
said I'll ever think about what you want
to do have a thing and then come back to
me and talk to me because you don't
wanna do this for the rest of your life
I'm like yeah no anyway a few days pass
so there was always some guy not too
energetic like you're not pleased but
I'm curious about this so it was like
somebody it was actually a guy who's
yeah after you and said it was a guy he
was my Foreman at work and you really
trusted this guy yeah you looked up to
yes yeah it was a nice guy you know
interesting how when you're young
especially if you're a young man like
you know I didn't have like a lot of
like father figures anything like that
around so any man that would give me
like attention or like so actual
interest you know that wasn't a damn PDF
file or someone if you have those in
your country but no unfortunately we do
I think they are universally okay round
we just make them fighting yeah yeah 100
percent I'd buy that paper
I'm sanction that one dude I call me
Kellerman in that one bro yeah yeah what
Sam but um but so I can just imagine
like the effect that that has like when
some guy like shows you interest in his
like here have a think about what you
want to do it really resonated with you
yeah for me I was always had an I always
had a problem with authority figures
right always that kid I had too much to
say I was a loudmouth I was always
getting in trouble you know I was an
idiot I was it was a dick you know and
this guy he knew how to speak to me it
was a nice guy and he and he said that
to me said you think about what you want
to do and fortunately the job didn't
require much brainpower so I it gave me
a lot of time to think and I thought
about it and I went up to him one day I
said make I've decided what I want to do
and he put down his clipboard and he
came off and he's like what is he and he
thought I was gonna see how kids I'm
gonna go to school I'm gonna study to be
this that and the other and I said and
this is 2003 I said I'm gonna be a
professional fire and he was like oh my
god I thought you were smart I thought
what do you mean you've gotta be a
professional fire I might make I should
do a lot of martial arts when I was a
kid and he's looking at me like what are
you talking about what is this I think I
gave this [ __ ] three weeks to think
about that and I'm like no seriously me
trust me I was very good and I brought
in this whole kickboxing video of me
kickboxing he's like oh yeah all right
you know they said that was just fueled
of aggression the guy sucked yeah I know
but you know anyway so we're oh yeah
quit work I moved to another city
started training and the rest is history
Wow how I got into it did you enjoy that
clip well you really would have enjoyed
it if he was watching on a TCL TV TCL is
America's fastest growing TV
Brande it's so fast it's the Carl Lewis
of television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com